hi there everybody it's Kevin Van Horn
here at GameSpot and I'm seated with
Sarah Orlovsky and you're here to show
us Blitzkrieg 3 and I'm sure you're
excited because you've you've come a
long way for your press tour and you're
leaving San Francisco up to this so I'm
glad you found time to stop by thank you
very much hello everybody
I'd be happy to show you district 3 and
all we've got at this point at least
which is alpha stage of the game so why
don't you set up the stage for like I
mean I don't know how many people out
there have played or necessarily even
heard of blitzkrieg wanna blitzkrieg -
they seem to be come from the you know
the heyday of the realtime strategy game
so why don't you fill us in on what
these games are so the first and second
blitzkrieg they were real time strategy
games focused on the tactical battles so
they didn't have any base and they have
a set of the troops and the mission and
you have to accomplish this mission with
this set of troops and you can also
advance the units between the missions
better progress them better and so on so
far in blitz blitzkrieg 3 we decided to
make a next step to make it online and
actually that's why it took so long big
time for the real time strategies not
anymore
very kind of stagnating in evolution
there is no new ideas in RTSs
for the past many years at least and we
also didn't have any new ideas for many
years so we didn't want just do the same
game again and again
fortunately RTS is helped us to do to
make lots of subgenres and I mean as an
industry and we have like mobile games
you have tower defense games all these
sub genres which came from there RTS but
not there the main generate south so
in online there were also several
efforts to do the memorial yes and I
think we found the solution finally how
to do it so we call it asynchronous
multiplayer so where we combine the best
elements and blending them together from
both single-player and multiplayer
symbol is Creek 3 we'll finally
introduced the base but it's not the
base which exists in the session is the
base which wishes which built between
the session and which visualize the
progress and you can do it up upgrade
the buildings construct but the unit's
upgrade the units we have a tech tree
you have generals etc etc and then you
make your army and go fight the battles
versus either bots or multiplayer
battles against the other opponents but
while you are online your opponents are
flying
so you're just preparing your defenses
on the base and you make it lots of
thinking while you're doing that and
then you kind of compete your wits with
the attacker and so you attack the
enemies who actually constructed the
game for you and the first two bliss
creeks were very famous for their for
the mods and add-ons so we had more than
hundred mods for the game because we
have very sophisticated map editor which
allowed to do all this mods in please
click 3 we decided can integrate these
features of this material into the game
itself basically you creating your own
defenses and creating the maps for the
other players to play through so right
now it's not very complicated that it's
very simple just moving the buildings
upgrading them putting minefields
Hedgehog this kind of stuff but in the
future we will introduce before the
launch we actually introduced aviation
like airplanes and counter-attacks and
airplanes after the launch will do very
small and simple scripting things and
she'll be able to
the triggers and do certain surprises
and counter-attacks for the attacking
armies and so on the firm now the the
base building that you're talking about
does that does that take place entirely
outside of the pressures of real-time
combat at the same time do I get I get
to go in there I get to to build my base
the way I want it to be and then when
I'm ready
can I signal that I'm prepared to be
attacked is that is that how that sort
of works between between players you're
being attacked not like every five
minutes right
basically most the time you are attacked
when you're offline so basically going
offline means that you're ready to be
attacked right and an average will get
like five plus attacks during your
offline period for like a day so if you
play a couple hours a day this is
probably what you would expect so what
you're talking about sort of sort of
recalls for me something like some
things mobile games have tried such as
clash of clans or or something like that
is that something that you looked to for
you know for some thoughts on how you
could turn that into and an actual
strategy game as opposed to a thing that
masquerades we no offense to clash of
clans but you know I think of that as
more as something that's for keeping my
tapping fingers busy but doesn't really
involve actually a whole lot from me on
the when it comes to an actual battle is
that is that sort of where you're trying
to deviate though from that is like when
it comes to battle you actually have
this real real time strategy you know
combat here on yes so many ideas came
from the social games to the beginning
if you remember backyard monsters from
kicks I and so I think this was the
first game where asynchronous
multiplayer and strategy gaming can
emerged and then with the great examples
in mobile space when it was very well
developed by clash of clans boom
bunch of alert I don't like hundreds of
clones but these were the titles we
which showed there the power of
asynchronous gameplay being pretty
shallow games by themselves what we want
to do we want to keep this great idea
and make it properly on a PC space with
a full-blown gameplay experience and
actually we started the game before
clash of clans it was more than three
years ago but we we saw what happened
there and we learned lots of lessons
from the mobile games etc but still once
again we're bringing into the full scale
to PC and there are many other games not
many but there's some other games
actually doing the same thing right now
if you know like mighty quest for epic
loot from Ubisoft or Dark Souls 2 the
certain extent like cos drivers in it
racing games etc etc so the whole thing
is coming to there to the big scale and
I think it's very nice emerging trend
which actually defines substantially
you'll be in play and it's a shame that
it wasn't done before
so when you say asynchronously does that
generally mean that the AI is going to
be taking over that the dai understands
what units the that player has available
and that
how does that how does that way I is not
the sitting in the I is controlling your
enemy okay so you were you playing as a
full-scale RTS battle but that on the
other side it's AI but this AI is
created not nothing I created but the
units and the patterns and figures
actually created by another person okay
so this is sort of like what you might
see in you know some racing games
nowadays where where it understands you
know AI like human behavior and tries to
replicate that is that it's not hard to
do isn't replicating a behavior okay
okay so yeah I has certain patterns but
and you have certain ways to influence
that yeah I the way you want so for
example you put you can put units on
different stances put certain triggers
or for example I can put the
dive-bombers to defend the certain
region and once your your tank will
enter this region the dive bombers will
try to kill you take to kill a tank as a
counter-attack okay or you can put
certain reserves of the units which they
flank you and go into the back once
which if certain triggers these kind of
things they're not yet there because
it's alpha build but right these are the
things which we would allow be part of
defensive strategies for the players so
in this way they kind of influence the
eye how to defend okay our particular
map so this is all stuff that I can that
I can set up in advance it's part of the
base building process exactly so that's
what I said from beginning it's kind of
blend between single-player and
multiplayer and will allow you to create
pretty much your own map and your own
mission for the old players who will try
to crack it oh goodness surgery we've
talked so much about so much it's not to
come back you know not at all but I I
worry that I might have missed touching
on something that you meant that you
meant to talk about that I haven't
gotten to is there anything about
blitzkrieg three that you money we've
missed
okay money okay how is how much is
blitzkrieg three gonna cost okay so we
with selling pre-orders right now for
$30 okay which I believe pretty
reasonable and pre-order includes three
campaigns and multiplayer access once we
start alpha testing public alpha testing
infirmary okay later on after the launch
we will open the game for free just for
multiplayer so you can still buy the
full version with the three campaigns
and multiplayer but it will be more
expensive sure or you can just start
playing multiplayer for free and then
purchase the campaigns each but one by
one as a DLC okay and what if I'm
totally just in a multiplayer is there
is there room for microtransactions
there is no they one be any
microtransactions and multiplayer but it
would be premium accounts which will
double your XP and and resources which
you get from the missions so which
basically increase the speed of your
progression in the game but we will not
be selling any pay2win items so
basically there is no micro transactions
so that's the point right
now if I buy the whole package outright
does that mean that that I sort of get
all the benefits of that premium upgrade
that multiplayer only people would get
you will get one in two months of
premium account as well but then they
would have to pay again okay so that's
more or less sort of more like an MMO
traditional MMO structure where you pay
for the game and then pay a fee for
except that you still can continue
playing without paying right on the just
slower pace of a develop it
so it's optional it's not a mandatory
subscription okay so if I do subscribe
I'm really subscribing for the
convenience yes of time spent
differently as all mm-hmm
alright what else time well timing you
know
obviously you're talking about the the
alpha tests in February mm-hmm I think
you said so Wendy when do you expect a
full launch to come this year
so we expecting better version to come
out April okay this year and the
full-scale launch by the end of the year
sometime in 2015 and that's where we're
not gonna lair oh it down beyond that
we'll just say sometime yes
but I should say thank you of course
thank you for coming in thanks for
making us part of your your whirlwind US
tour before you get back to the the more
arduous tasks of actually making the
game and I'd rather you spend more your
more time doing that
I think but thank you to your
compatriots that joined you and thanks
to everybody that's that's watching and
listening let's create three sometime in
2015 we don't know when yet and until
then I guess
tune in to GameSpot for more looks at
all the games you're most interested in
you